[Musik]
corona nachgehakt in kohle nachgehakt
spreche ich jetzt mit professor hendrik
speck und ich spreche über etwas was uns
alle so ein bisschen angst macht nämlich
omikron omikron die neue variante die
mutation ist die wirklich so gefährlich
wie manche sagen müssen wir da eine
große sorge haben eigentlich können wir
dann noch gar nicht so viel zu sagen
weil die omikron variante kennen wir
bisher nur vom genom also sie wurde
sequenziert und dadurch natürlich
entdeckt das ist eine komplett neue
variante ist aber wir können zwar vom g9
so ein bisschen ablesen was so eine neue
variante bedeutet
und wir können auch als geologe da so
ein paar rückschlüsse ziehen aber wir
können nicht vorhersagen die sie in
seiner gesamtheit so ein virus sich dann
verhält ob sie es besser übertragbar ist
ob die impfstoffe schlechter wirken das
müssen wir dann erst noch im labor
testen und dazu muss das virus erst mal
an gezüchtet werden also isoliert werden
und dann im labor zb mit blutproben von
geimpften menschen zusammengebracht
werden um zu schauen die das verhältnis
verhalten des virus wirklich ist haben
sie erwartet dass so etwas wie omikron
auftakt also dass das besondere an
omikron ist ja es hat 80 über 80
unterschiedliche mutationen im genom
viele davon sind bekannt aus anderen
varianten also wir sehen zum beispiel
aus der alpha und data varianten
variante kombinationen da drin die wir
vorher schon mal gesehen haben was ist
besonders macht das so viele auf einmal
auftreten und 32 mutationen im
oberflächenprotein vorkommen also im
spike protein und das ist natürlich das
protein wo dass die impfstoffe und die
immunantworten am ende an setzen dass so
viele mutationen über die zeit passieren
damit würde man schon rechnen dass es
eben eine natürliche evolution des virus
scheint das besondere an dieser variante
ist dass es wohl in einem patienten sich
über sehr lange zeit entwickelt hat man
nimmt an dass das in einem hiv-patienten
gewesen ist
dass sie immun system einfach nicht
richtig das virus bekämpfen konnte und
dann über einen sehr langen verlauf das
virus eine ja sich weiterentwickeln
konnte er strickt sie sind spezialist
experte für hiv sieht schon sehr lange
schulen daran war dass abzusehen dass es
möglicherweise eine variante gibt dir
war einem solchen patienten oft also ist
es anzunehmen dass solche varianten sich
präferenz ii allen
personen mehr oder patienten bilden wo
das immunsystem nicht so gut
funktioniert mehr also auch in patienten
zum beispiel die
krebserkrankung haben onkologisch
behandelt werden da sie häufiger so
längere verlaufe von corona
viruserkrankungen und wo das virus auch
sich sehr viel schneller und weiter
entwickelt das ist jetzt eine hiv
patient war das ist natürlich
naheliegend aber es war jetzt nicht
speziell da sie gerät damit gerechnet
habe dass sv patient sein müssen das
heißt im grunde ist da ein virus der
sich verändert in allen patienten und
man entdeckt ihn gar nicht wie kommt er
denn dann sozusagen in eine
südafrikanische variante wie wir jetzt
festgestellt haben wo möglicherweise
südafrika auch gar nicht der
ausgangspunkt war also man muss sich das
so vorstellen dass sich ein patient mit
firmen tv infiziert war mit corona
infiziert hat und über woche mit dem
virus infiziert war aber kein sicht das
selber nicht reduzieren konnte selber
nicht geheilt werden sich selber nicht
ein konto vom virus vielleicht wurde ja
auch behandelt man hat versucht
vielleicht auch mit antikörpern dagegen
vorzugehen und das hat nicht gut die
behandlung hat mich gut angeschlagen und
so konnte sich das virus über wochen und
vielleicht sogar monate weiter
entwickeln wir wissen ja nicht wie lange
diese entwicklung war hier in
deutschland
beobachten wie auch solche
entwicklungsschritte in patienten die zb
ökologisch behandelt sind die kein gutes
immunsystem haben da können wir schon
auch über wochen in einigen patienten
sehen gewesen virus auch
weiterentwickelt dass es jetzt nicht
unbedingt überraschend wie das jetzt
aber in dem speziellen fall bionicon
verlaufen ist das kann ich natürlich
nicht sagen es wird ja immer wieder auch
gesagt von den gegnern des impfens wenn
menschen geimpft sind können sich solche
mutationen schneller und er entwickeln
ist das so nein dass es so gar nicht so
also mittlerweile gibt es studien und
auch epidemiologische studien die zeigen
dass die länder die am schnellsten im um
fortschritt sind wo die meisten menschen
geimpft sind desto weniger tritt in
diesen ländern virus evolution auf man
kann sich die jetzt noch nicht genau ist
noch nicht völlig geklärt woran es liegt
dass das nicht so schnell eine virus
evolution in
ländern mit hoher impfquote ist also
warum die herabgesetzt ist aber man kann
sich das vielleicht so vorstellen dass
das virus zeit braucht sich zu
entwickeln in der evolution vor zu
streiten bei einem gewünschten person
greift aber sofort auch wenn er sich
infizieren sollte greift sofort das
immunsystem ab und man lässt den virus
überhaupt keine zeit sich zu entwickeln
und darum sieht man wahrscheinlich auch
weniger in der evolution oder weniger
veränderungen bei geimpften menschen als
bei uns wenn wir aber jetzt mitten in
der vierten welle sind und diese
mutation omikron noch auftaucht und sie
sagen es ist eigentlich sinnvoll diese
mutationen auch zu stoppen oder
zumindest zu behindern durch impfen ist
dann nicht eine impfpflicht sinnvoll
also erstmal muss man sagen dass wir bei
der omicron variante ja auf der einen
seite diese mutationen
oberflächenprotein haben wodurch
vielleicht einige ins antworten also
einige der immunantworten wegfallen
können aber viel wichtiger ist ein
impfstoff wird gar nicht mehr so stark
na ja das können wir ja nur das können
wir ja nicht wirklich sagen ob er
weniger stark wirkt oder nicht aber man
kann mit so vielen mutationen damit
rechnen dass der impfstoff vielleicht
ein bisschen herabgesetzt ist in seiner
wirksamkeit wodurch kommt es aber
zustande dass wir trotzdem noch genug
immunantworten haben ist dass wir ja
nicht nur mit einem antikörper gegen das
virus vorgehen sondern mit einer ganzen
armada einer ganzen armee von
unterschiedlichen antikörpern die das
oberflächenprotein dass wir uns
angreifen jetzt hat man eben mögen mag
es sein dass 23 dieser antikörper
antworten wegfallen aber man hat ja
immer noch den rest der antikörper die
dagegen vorgehen daher hilft auch eine
booster impfung weil wenn man gegen
korona jetzt einen booster impfung nimmt
dann werden auch diese sub dominanten
antworten also die kleineren antworten
werden auch gepustet und können dann vor
allem auch gegen micron wertvoll sein
wenn wir in allernächster zeit wissen
wie die impfung zum beispiel gegen
omikron wirkt und wie gefährlich dieses
virus ist oder müssen wir da eine sehr
lange zeit in den laboren abwarten wo
geforscht wird also ich kann ja einmal
kurz erklären wie solches wissen dann
zustande kommt auf der einen seite
sind die biologen und die monologen
gefragt indem sie das virus erstmals
isolieren ansichten und dann in kontakt
mit plasma oder quasi blut von einem
geimpften einer geimpften person bringen
und dann schaut man sich das in vielen
wiederholungen an von vielen
verschiedenen menschen wird das plasma
genommen und geschaut wie gut das plasma
immer noch wurde das serum immer noch
das virus erkennen kann das ist so die
erste evidenz die war relativ schnell
bekommen werden zusätzlich müssen wir
epidemiologisch abwarten und schauen wie
häufig kommt es eigentlich zu impfen
durchbrüchen
omikron im vergleich zur data variante
oder im vergleich zum alfa variante das
sind so die daten die vielleicht ein
bisschen länger dauern und dann
natürlich auch vielleicht beobachtungs
fehler erst mal
ausgeräumt werden müssen
damit man nicht glaubt dass alles jetzt
ein grund liegt sondern vielleicht auch
andere faktoren eine rolle spielen das
dauert vielleicht ein bisschen spät
länger aber insgesamt glaube ich schon
dass wir in den nächsten wochen sehr
schnell dazu klarheit haben werden jetzt
haben auch die
impfstoffhersteller schon gesagt die
richten sich quasi schon darauf ein den
impfstoff so zu verändern gerade beim m
rna impfstoff etwas von biotech wie
schnell geht denn so etwas und kann man
dann tatsächlich diese neue variante
auch damit abwehren nun ist erstmal gut
dass die impfstoffhersteller für den
schlimmsten fall sich vorbereiten
nämlich dass sie im stoff wirkt wirkung
deutlich heruntergesetzt wie gesagt wir
wissen ja nicht wie wie sehr sie auch
unter gesetzt sein wird und dass sie
jetzt quasi ein bisschen zeit sparen die
herstellung eines neuen impfstoffes ist
nicht kompliziert die anpassung erstmal
es nicht so kompliziert und dann schon
einmal einen lebensstoff hergestellt
haben der gegen omikron optimal
funktionieren kann dann wird wird ja das
ergebnis da sein wie gut die impfstoffe
noch wirken und sie werden die
möglichkeit haben dann entweder eine
klinische studie zu machen die neuen
stoffe auf den markt zu bringen der vor
allem auch gut gegen nikon wirkt oder
die impfstoff wirkungen ist immer noch
gut genug und dann wird dieser impfstoff
erst mal ja nicht weiterentwickelt wenn
wir bei omikron ist mit einem
virus zu tun haben mit einer mutation zu
tun haben die sehr viel schneller
ansteckend ist da gibt es ja durchaus
die befürchtung dass das so sein könnte
die muss man dann damit umgeht ja also
die befürchtung wird ja daher das ja
einige mutationen gesehen haben
virus was darauf schließen könnte das
die
übertragbarkeit erhöht ist ob das jetzt
wirklich der fall ist das müssen wir
sehen dass können wir können wir
wirklich noch nicht sagen
der umgang mit omikron ist aber der
gleiche dann am ende die wir jetzt mit
delta haben also idealerweise im moment
impfen und postern und
h und l regeln und natürlich dann hohen
instanzen kontakt beschränkungen helfen
uns auch weiterhin dieses virus
einzelnen könnte es dazu kommen dass wir
wenn es unterstellt ansteckender wäre
tatsächlich in den öffentlichen bereich
stärker noch einmal reduzieren müssen
das heißt möglicherweise zu einer art
von
lokalen lockdown zu kommen müssten ich
finde das sehr spekulativ jetzt auch das
bild an die wand zu malen dass wir jetzt
mit einem super variante zu tun haben wo
wir eine enorme übertragung haben werden
dann natürlich muss man alle
möglichkeiten die man hat zur virus
eindämmung auch in betracht ziehen am
ende wenn es denn so wäre dass das eine
schlimmere wirklich schlimmere variante
es aber im moment wissen wir das alles
nicht und unser hauptproblem es gehe ich
eben ja schon mal gesagt hatte ist die
delta variante und das vor allem in den
südlichen bundesländer jetzt frage ich
zwar einen biologen aber kann sicherlich
auch sagen diese verbreitung um die welt
die versuchen jetzt alle länder
möglichst einigermaßen zu bremsen um
einfach zeit zu gewinnen wie lange kann
man das machen wann ist sozusagen der
virus eigentlich überall in dieser
mutation ja also wir werden das virus
nicht aufhalten können in der neuen
variante also wenn es eine variante
weltweit geben sollte die sich besser
durchsetzt als die anderen varianten
also wenn sie einen vorteil hat in der
verteilung zum beispiel in der
übertragung besser fluchtkaution von nun
system oder eine höhere virale fitness
wie wir das nennen
dann wird sich dieses virus auch
weltweit durchsetzen also sobald man
eigentlich diese mutationen entdeckt hat
irgendwo im moment ist sie
wahrscheinlich auch schon in anderen in
andere länder verteilt gewesen was man
ja jetzt sehr gut auch an omikron
gesehen hat wir werden die können die
verbreitung nur verlangsamen wir können
sie aber nicht dauerhaft aufhalten
könnte omikron vielleicht muss man auch
positiv am ende zu formulieren eine
mutation sein die schon zeigt dass das
virus vielleicht nicht mehr so
gefährlich werden könnte ja es gibt ja
die ersten also die ersten fälle die von
omikron beschrieben wurden das sind ja
jetzt ein paar hundert die sind
eigentlich alles im moment sehr milde
fälle also milde verläufe leichte
symptome aber keine schweren verläufe
man könnte davon natürlich ist er als
schlussfolgerung oder das ist nicht so
ein gefährliches virus damit solche
schlussfolgerungen werde ich aber
vorsichtig weil wir auch wenn etwas
jetzt noch nicht aufgetreten ist können
wir nicht abschließend sagen das ist ein
milderes virus geworden also in beide
richtung würde ich mit dem spekulation
im moment stand heute vorsichtig sein
weil wir weder sagen können ob es eher
milder geworden ist noch können wir
sagen es hat eine höhere übertragungs
wahrscheinlichkeit und ja die im stoff
burke schlechter da muss man eben erst
mal dass wissenschaftlicher forschung
ich muss sie aber jetzt mal abseits der
wissenschaft fragen die wissenschaftler
geraten ja gerade jetzt auch durch
omikron unter einem enormen druck ganz
schnell etwas sagen zu müssen über diese
neue mutation haben sie insgesamt den
eindruck dass wir uns nicht eigentlich
ein bisschen näher mal mit wissenschaft
beschäftigen und akzeptieren müssen dass
manche dinge einfach nicht so schnell
gehen wie wir es gerne haben wollen ja
also das leider im moment das problem
dass wir alle eine antwort auf omikron
zb haben wollen und wir sehr einfach
nicht geben können und jeder jeden
experten den ich dazu gehört habe die
haben sich alle gleich geäußert dass wir
nicht vorschnelle vorschnelle schlüsse
ziehen dürfen in alle richtungen
im grunde längst aber ja auch von der
debatte ab natürlich macht so eine
variante jetzt erstmal sorgen aber das
ist eine diskussion die man in der
epidemiologie und virologie belassen
sollte weil
das hauptproblem ist sind die
infektionszahlen bei uns und darauf
müssen wir uns konzentrieren ganz egal
welche variante das im moment ist
kontrollieren wir date kontrollieren wir
dadurch auch die omikron variante
[Musik]